al-jazeera's investigative unit has
obtained exclusive video revealing a
backlog of goods at China's biggest
export hub all that's causing a delay in
the supply of medical equipment for
healthcare workers around the world long
queues of trucks loaded with cargo at
shanghai airport are waiting to unload
at customs and hundreds of boxes are
piling up in warehouses China produces
nearly half the world's supply of
protective medical equipment notably to
the US and Europe but concerns are
growing its quality control rules on
exporting cargo is hampering efforts to
meet demand for personal protective
equipment wealth all is executive
producer of Al Jazeera's investigative
unit he joins us by Skype from
Winchester in the United Kingdom we'll
good to have you with us so why are
supplies stuck in China while the world
desperately needs them it's a very good
question Sammy I think it's the the rule
of unintended consequences in this case
China as you rightly said produces just
about half of the world's protective
medical equipment they exported very
large quantities of it to Europe back in
March when the pandemic started to take
grip unfortunately there were
significant cargos which had substandard
or counterfeit goods which caused a huge
amount of critical focus to come on
China very embarrassing for china is the
world's manufacturer as a response to
that they tightened up their export and
quality rules now it appears from having
talked to various shipping agencies in
in China those rules have been applied
in a very rigid bureaucratic manner and
in a slightly haphazard way which is
resulted in this enormous gridlock of
masks with surgical gowns ventilators
all of the material they're so
desperately needed currently by
frontline workers in the battle against
coded 19 well I just want to delve a
little bit deeper into something you
said there about substandard protective
equipment did any of that actually make
it out of China according to
you know through your investigation I
mean is there a possibility that people
somewhere in the world are relying on
faulty PPE it's on the record it's been
widely reported Italy Spain Holland I
think the UK also returned significant
batches of equipment which was seen to
be not made of the materials they
require for what's highly sensitive and
difficult work which which requires good
quality material as a barrier against a
virus so it's possible of course batches
got through that weren't returns but the
key thing is China actually did react to
this did tighten up the rules but the
consequences of that of causing perhaps
may be far greater issues as we know you
know cargo stacking up hospitals health
authorities desperately trying to get
this equipment and failing to get it
through the system because the red tape
has become you know far more intricate
and complex well are they dealing with
that now I mean are the rules and the
red tape being changed to kind of find a
balance between making sure nothing
faulty gets out but also making sure
that everything isn't held up well just
last night Sammy
there was a significant cargo of PPE
personal protective equipment that was
bound for a country which desperately
needs it that was seized and impounded
and held by Chinese customs officials
because they would they told the
exporter that the packaging didn't meet
new regulations the exporter in this
case had no idea the rules have changed
I'm you know exasperation followed and
the equipment was delayed yet further so
there are efforts to get this moving but
from from what I'm hearing from people
on the ground that continues to be a
slightly haphazard and very bureaucratic
imposition of these rules which were
designed to improve the quality of the
equipment but it's slowed down the
supply well this there's been concern if
not accusations of countries playing
politics with the supply of medicine and
personal protective equipment have you
found any evidence of that you
in the situation you've been looking at
in China we haven't found any evidence
of politics being played we have heard a
lot of anecdotal evidence of businessman
rushing in to see an opportunity buying
large quantities of peepee entire
production and runs from companies
warehousing them and sitting on them
waiting for the price to go up now
that's not politics that's obviously
just stood up raw business and that's a
major concern now to governments and
health authorities trying to obtain
equipment let alone export it in terms
of politics we haven't seen any
suggestion that this is political it
looks more like bad bureaucracy and a
sort of haphazard application of a
policy all right good to talk to you
always will thorn therefrom Algeciras
investigative unit thanks so much for
that well thank you